I should say oh yeah how are you hydrate
thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can I help
so my husband and I have around $250,000
worth of debt well most of it being
student loans I know
no mortgage because you don't have a
house and we also have to lease vehicles
we just sold one we have another one
that has is over around two thousand
miles so we've been trying to save up
for a car in order to drive that instead
of the leased car and we have a family
wedding that's coming up in August in
another country it's my husband's
brother and we've decided in order to
help keep our gives owned company up and
not take too much of a hit to have my
husband go and me stay in the issue with
that was that his family was not happy
with the decision and it was very
upsetting and we got you know called
selfish and it was tough emotionally to
handle that in and we were just
wondering are we being too insensitive
should we both go so we're kind of in a
pickle death so it's his family wealthy
so they're all broke but they're doing a
destination wedding internationally well
I don't know what brothers situation is
and as well I mean if you do a
destination wedding and you invite all
your family that's broke it's kind of
unfair that's what I personally thought
right yeah so where's the wedding I
didn't go public
okay no it's not too bad I mean what
will it cost you get down there so one
things are good for their date is around
almost $700 for a weekend mm-hmm and
what's your household income we make
around $60,000 a year combined Wow and
you have $200,000 in bed if I cry myself
to sleep every night yes
so how much worth how much of the
200,000
these two cars well the Juke so I got
rid of one of the cars we got rid of one
of the leases so we don't have that $500
payment that was the car finish that
part of it was that part of the $200,000
in debt that you gave me no so there's
in addition to that okay right and how
much is how much do you owe on the other
car I see you don't have that in the
200,000 either yeah okay and what is the
200,000 all student loans so it's a
hundred thousand is student loans and
it's 90 thousand my student loans and
the rest are credit cards and bank loans
okay so what are your degrees in my
degree is in school counseling so I took
long within my bachelor's and master's
degree and he started nursing
practitioner degree but didn't finish so
he took so long for that so now we have
that long or that guy both of you work
yes and you only make $60,000 a year
right okay Wow so your master's degree
and all of your work was a really poor
investment all right based on the career
field that you've chosen out of it
anyway because I mean if we just take
yours alone you say $100,000 in debt I
mean you're making 130 no I'm making so
I I guess I met after taxes I'm making
around I'm making 50 but after taxes I
want to fix my car yeah well you're
making 50 and what does he make he just
started working a new job so right now
he makes around 50 he just started a
teaching job but that wasn't okay so
that's like a hundred
1550s like a hundred she make $100,000 a
year
alright that's a little different um
well I I um
I mean seven hundred dollars one way or
the other is not going to change your
life to the positive order the negative
it's more the point of who runs your
house your mother-in-law or you too well
and that's what this comes down to it's
more of a boundaries issue and you know
I I might be inclined to spend the 700
except that everybody wanted me to and
then that makes me not want to do it
because you're trying to tell me how to
run my house
all of you but yeah seven hundred bucks
if that's all that's going to cost you
get down there that's really out of
$100,000 of your income and you've got a
$200,000 mess the seven hundred ollars
is not the issue I mean you're gonna
find other stuff that happens that
that's gonna be $700 on the way the
other and both of you need to get extra
jobs and yeah you got to sell this other
car that's a lot more important than the
$700 I think it's more of a boundary
issue of you know you don't get to
decide what I'm gonna do that's not you
know you don't live here and and
sometimes you do things not out of guilt
tripping but just because you want to be
kind to someone but but as soon as I
start guilt-tripping me I tend to go the
other way so I don't care if you go it
doesn't matter to me I think you've got
a lot bigger fish to fry than that one
so I'm not sure this is a sort I want to
fall on if it was seven thousand dollars
yeah I mean you're trying to fly me to
wherever for seven grand that'd be
different but seven hundred bucks is I
mean you can work extra for a month
delivering pizzas and go write what you
need to probably be doing anyway
to earn some money so it's just you know
there's so many big numbers here and
that is such a small number that it's
more about the relationship issues the
boundary issues for me than than the
actual dollars in this case
and so that that's you know the way I'd
look at it it's it's so presumptuous
folks for you guys any of you to do a
wedding and I've run into this a bunch
of times over the years and you know
it's fine if you do a wedding out of the
country into a destination wedding or
something
that's fine or do a wedding in your city
and your whole family lives in New York
and you want to get married in LA
because that's where you live but you
don't have the right then to be angry if
they can't make it over there that's
presumptuous and that's out of line you
know if you're all worried about
everybody making it go where they are
don't put it in the freaking Dominican
Republic you know that's just
presumptuous as crud it's just you're
presuming upon my money you're spending
my money and then you're pissed I won't
that's just weird